[Music]
she's great been a huge fan of her
songwriting for years and years and so
to get to do a song with her was you
know really dream come true
it was fun she's always been a huge
advocate for songwriters and great songs
and i think
we obsessed something that we need more
of and i think she's really been a
trailblazer
if i was a cowboy i'd be the queen that
was definitely a bucket list deal for me
i've been a fan of hers for a long time
so it's cool called it cool to see your
name on there for sure aside from his
incredible collaboration with miranda
luke's new album growing up features a
ton of tracks that all his fans can
relate to i'd still be the same guy they
knew back in the day who was burning cds
just to give away
what is the journey that you hope
listeners will go on when they listen to
this i think the idea for me was you're
kind of like stuck in the middle of
these two phases of your life you know
and so i think
i've always wanted to kind of
you know continue to grow with my fan
base so there are a lot of songs that i
feel like
are on there that i would have written
when i was 21 and there are songs that
you know
that i only would have written having
been you know 32 and where i'm at now
[Music]